[Music]
remembrance weekend is one of the most
significant moments of the year for the
royal family a time when they all gather
together but we now know the queen is
going to miss the british legion's
festival of remembrance at the royal
albert hall
a statement from the palace said that
following on from their recent advice
that the queen should rest for a few
days her majesty's doctors have advised
that she should continue to rest for at
least the next two weeks the doctors
have advised that her majesty can
continue to undertake light desk-based
duties during this time including some
virtual audiences but not to undertake
any official visits her majesty regrets
that this means she'll be unable to
attend the festival of remembrance on
saturday the 13th of november they
stressed it is still her firm intention
to be at the cenotaph on remembrance
sunday where in recent years prince
charles has placed the nation's wreath
on her behalf
she lived through the second world war
she saw her father lead the nation and
she served herself and for her
this is a prime duty of the monarch
she'll hate missing it but she'll try to
be ready for the remembrance sunday
service this was the queen's last public
outing a week and a half ago
since then she spent a night in hospital
after having preliminary tests we don't
know what for and canceled two major
engagements a trip to northern ireland
and her appearance at the climate summit
in glasgow
i understand that the queen has been
well enough to record a message that
will be played at cop 26 and again the
palace have used that phrase saying that
she is in good spirits they know that
people will understandably be concerned
about her she is after all 95 years old
but they want to stress that doctors are
being cautious and she is still working
away behind the scenes
this week she's welcomed two new
ambassadors to the uk
i'm very glad to have the chance to
see you if only mechanically this
morning
and presented her award for poetry the
queen no doubt also wanting to send a
subtle message of reassurance as she's
so often done during her reign
rhiannon mills sky news at windsor
castle